sanderson residence  branderson sanderson ah king hopping  writer's block are we  no just totally fresh and new ideas  i read your new book 80 000 words yeah i  wrote that this morning in my dream  journal tell that to your  national book award huh oh wait oh oh  you don't have it what are you gonna do  oh you don't have it guess what i know  obama at least my magic systems make  sense  unlike what is it that you call yours  cocaine  what car i meant i meant to say car look  uh brandon you're kind of wasting my  time i'm opening my it chapter two  royalties and i have a feeling it's  gonna be a big one this week so if you  don't mind just giving me a little  teensy bit of space buddy that'd be nice  that'd be great  nerd  back in business baby  [Music]  you